PROFESSOR: So, now we come to
the place where arithmetic,
modulo n or
remainder arithmetic,
starts to be a little bit
different and that involves
taking inverses and cancelling.
Let's look at that.
So first of all,
we've already observed
that we have these
basic congruence rules
that if a and b are congruent
then c and d are congregant,
then a plus c and b
plus d are congruent,
a times c and b times
d are congruent.
So, that's the sense in
which arithmetic mod n is
a lot like ordinary arithmetic.
But here's the main difference.
Let's look at this one.
8 times 2 is 16,
which means it's
congruent to 6 mod 10, which
is the same as 3 times 2.
So, 8 times 2 is
congruent to 3 times 2.
And you'd be tempted,
maybe, to cancel the twos.
And what happens then, well
then you could discover that you
think that 8 is congruent
to 3 mod 10, which it ain't.
So in short, you can't
cancel arbitrarily.
You can't cancel two, in
this case in particular.
So, that leads, naturally, to
the question of when can you
cancel a number?
When can you cancel a number k
when both sides of inequality
are multiplied by k and
I'd like to cancel k?
And the answer is simple,
when k has no common factors
with a modulus n.
So, the proof of that is
based on the following idea.
Let's say that a number k
prime is an inverse of k mod n.
If k prime times k is
congruent to 1 mod n.
So, k prime is like 1 over
k with respect to mod n.
But of course, 1 over k is going
to be a fraction unless k is 1.
And so, k prime is going
to be an integer that
simply acts like 1 over k.
So, how are we
going to prove this?
And it's going to turn out to be
an easy consequence of the fact
that the gcd is a
linear combination.
So, how am I going to
prove-- find this k
prime that's an inverse of k?
Well remember, given
the gcd of k and n is 1,
I have a linear combination
of k and n is 1.
So, s times k plus
t times n is 1.
But if you stare at that for
a moment, what that means
is that k prime is simply
the coefficient s of k.
So, all you have to do is
apply the pulverizer to k and n
to get the coefficient s of k
in the linear combination of k
and n is equal to 1.
Let's look at that
slightly more carefully
and see what's going on.
I have that sk plus tn is 1.
So, that means in particular,
since they're equal,
they're certainly congruent
to each other, modulo n.
sk plus tn is
congruent to 1 mod n.
But, n is congruent to 0 mod n.
So, this becomes t times 0, and
we're left with sk congruent
1 mod n, which is exactly
the definition of s
being an inverse of k.
Now, I can also cancel k if
it's relatively prime to n.
And the reason is that if I
have ak equivalent to bk mod n
and the gcd of k
and n is 1, then
I have this k prime
that's an inverse of k.
So, I just multiply both
sides by the inverse
of k, namely k prime.
And I get that the left hand
side is a times k, k inverse.
And the right hand side
is b times k, k inverse.
And of course, that's a times
1 is equivalent to b times 1.
And so, a is
congruent to b mod n.
So I can cancel, in
that case, trivially.
And in fact, you can work out
the converse implications.
The punch line of this--
well first of all, this
is the cancellation rule.
You can cancel providing
that the gcd of k and n
is 1 if k is
relatively prime to n.
So, this is the summary.
[? k is ?] cancelable
mod n if and only
if k has an inverse mod n, if
and only if the gcd of k and n
is 1, which I can restate as
k is relatively prime to n.
And that's the story.